situation toujours extrêmement tendue en
tunisie et depuis douze jours des
affrontements opposent régulièrement la
police à des manifestants notamment de
jeunes diplômés qui ne trouvent pas de
travail pas de travail c'est le cri de
désespoir lancés à sidi bouzid le 17
décembre 2010 par des tunisiens sans
perspective d'avenir
ce jour là mohamed bouazizi un jeune
vendeur ambulant à qui la police a
confisqué sa cargaison de fruits
s'immole par le feu
dès le lendemain des émeutes éclatent
dans la ville nous vivons chaque jour un
peu plus d'humiliations de pauvreté de
souffrance le 27 décembre
le soulèvement populaire atteint la
capitale tunis des images de
manifestations toujours rares postés sur
les réseaux sociaux car les médias
tunisiens sont sous le contrôle du
président ben ali
régime dictatorial contre lequel se
tournent maintenant les manifestants
c'est le début de ce que l'on nommera la
révolution du jasmin mais laurent était
au départ relatif au droit au travail au
droit à une vie digne
toute fuite après fait défaut quand ils
exigent le départ de ben ali ben ali
réagi avec violence le 8 janvier à thala
et kasserine
la répression tourne au bain de sang
vingt-trois civils trouvent la mort les
manifestants sont de jeunes chômeurs de
moins de 25 ans ils sont sortis pour
exprimer leur colère mais les forces de
l'ordre leur ont tiré dessus avec des
balles réelles
le pays s'enfonce chaque jour dans la
violence au soir du 13 janvier après
avoir instauré un couvre-feu à tunis ben
ali fait des concessions pour conserver
le pouvoir pour la troisième fois depuis
le début des émeutes
le président ben ali s'est exprimé ce
soir à la télévision
il a exclu de briguer un nouveau mandat
a promis une liberté totale de la presse
et une enquête indépendante sur les
troubles qui secoue le pays
malgré ce discours d'apaisement la
répression se poursuit dans le pays
mais les tunisiens sont décidés plus que
jamais à renverser la dictature
90 morts à peu près ya eu souvent 1000
blessés au moins qu'ils soient pas morts
et blessés courir au soir du 14 janvier
la nouvelle historique tombe le
président ben ali a quitté le pouvoir
est probablement le pays c'est son
premier ministre qui assure ce soir
l'intérim ben ali et sa famille trouve
refuge en arabie saoudite
mais le pouvoir est toujours aux mains
du rcd le parti de ben ali
face à la rue qui ne décolère pas le
premier ministre mohammed ghannouchi
démissionne le 27 février le premier des
printemps arabes aura causé la mort de
338 tunisien
[Musique]